So to summarize, our discussion of
recommender systems in some sense, the
filtering task or recommending task is
easy and in some other senses, and the
task is actually difficult, so it's
easy because the users expectations,
though in this case the system it takes
initiative to push the information to
the user so the user doesn't really
make.
An effort, so any recommendation is
better than nothing, right?
So unless you recommend the order,
noisy items or useless documents, if
you can recommend some useful
information, users general would
appreciate it, so that's in that sense
that's easy.
However, filtering is actually much
harder task than retrieval because it
has you have to make a binary decision
and you can't afford waiting for a lot
of items.
And then you're going to see.
whether 1 item is better than others.
You have to make a decision when you
see this item.
The thing about the news filtering as
soon as you see the news and you have
to decide whether the news would be
interesting to a user.
If you wait for a few days.
Even if you can make accurate
recommendation of the most relevant
news, the utility is going to be
significantly decreased.
Another reason why it's hard, it's
because the data sparseness.
If you think of this as a learning
problem in collaborative filtering, for
example, it's purely based on learning
from the past ratings, so if you
don't have many ratings, this really
not that much you can do.
And yeah, just mentioned this cold
start problem.
This is actually a very serious serious
problem, but of course there are
strategies that have been proposed to
solve the problem and there are
different strategies that you can use
to alleviate the problem.
You can use for example, more user
information to assess their similarity
instead of using the preferences of
these users on these items, there may
be additional information available
about the user.
etc and.
And we also talked about the two
strategies for filtering task one is
content based, where we look at item
similarity.
The other is collaborative filtering where
we look at the user similarity and they
obviously can be combined in a
practical system.
You can imagine the general would have
to be combined so that will give us a
hybrid strategy for filtering.
And we also could recall that we talked
about push versus pull as two
strategies for getting access to the
text data and recommended system is to
help users in the push mode and search
engines are certain users in the pull
mode.
Obviously the tool should be combined
and they can be combined to have a
system that can support the user
with multiple mode information access.
So in future we could anticipate the
such a system to be more useful to
user.
An either this is the active research
area, so there are a lot of new
algorithms being proposed all the
time.
In particular, those new algorithms
tend to use a lot of context
information.
Now the context here could be the
context of the user and that it could
be also context of documents or items.
The items are not isolated and they are
connected in many ways.
The users might form social network
as well, so there's a rich context
there that we can leverage in order to
really solve the problem well and then
that's an active research area where also
machine learning algorithms that have
been applied.
Here are some additional readings in
the Handbook called Recommender Systems
and has a collection of a lot of good.
Articles that can give you an overview
of a number of specific approaches to
recommended systems.